first of all let's talk fashion cuz this
dress is amazing and this is like I love
the Amaze when we can get a gown on and
goodness so tell me how you picked this
look this is actually very different
from me my stylist I've been trying to
grow and expand my tastes hit song on
your own now honey my goodness thank you
I'm actually wearing a Carolina so we
were just sitting watching your guy win
it's so exciting so why don't you guys
have such a big hit song right now what
does this mean like just to be in this
world right now it means everything and
I just always take the time to look back
at myself as a little girl only dreaming
of being in this position watching the
AMAs year after year so just to
physically be here and to have you know
number one song is insane and the first
record that I actually gave to the world
everything's happening the way that like
I guess it was meant to now has love
ever lied to you
which is why I'm singing okay I love
this I'm happy yeah just no no
contenders no contenders who did we see
on the carpet that was looking for a
lover
I think bebe Rexha oh you guys got to go
on a double date I thought it was maybe
a guy I could connect my girl yeah I
mean on that way but yeah we love each
other for this so if the first song you
put out as a solo artist is the number
one smash what else you have in your
back pocket ready for the world have
some tricks up my sleeve most definitely
I have something coming out this Friday
I've got you
and then in the next few days I record
with Calvin err no and how did that come
about
um I believe he just like reached out
and he hit me and he was like yo what
did you think about what do you think
about this and I was like this chick is
like fire we got to put this out so now
listen what a huge fan of his I mean
like oh my god
what is it like to be at an AMAs that is
so girl-power focused I mean we're in
the backstage right now Jennifer Lopez
is on stage right now performing a
sequin pantsuit honey so you know what
is it like for sure does it feel to be a
woman in music at this point I think
that you know we're having such an
amazing time right now we're so full of
ideas and it's really amazing just to
see I mean like you said that's a really
amazing point like the whole night I
feel like women have just been killing
it and on top and it's it's beautiful to
really see especially in a
male-dominated field it is you know it
is what it is but I mean I think that
we're definitely holding our own and
showing them over tomato
[Music]